to be not racist is a discursive form of
racist violence
so you've got these anti-racist
activists urging people to be racist in
order to not be racist it makes no sense
if you redefine words and then deny that
you are redefining the words
you effectively end up gaslighting the
world
what is a woman is not a gotcha question
we all know
the difference but we're expected to
proclaim that we don't that there is no
difference
if if you can't sit there and tell me
what a woman is
then i don't trust you on anything else
but if you say what everyone knows you
open yourself up to accusation and you
can be the next to be condemned we can't
vote these people out you can vote in a
labor government or tory government
you're still going to get the woke if
the machinery of government is grinding
in that direction there is nothing you
can do when a school
board a county school board not only
removes the books from the shelves but
burns them
and calls it a flame purification
ceremony
and they can't see what the implications
of that are i don't believe they could
have done that if they could see with
any sense
did you know that you can ask guests
your questions that's right when you
join our local community not only will
you know who we're about to interview
you have the opportunity to ask them
your questions you have the chance to
ask jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norcott
simon evans larry elder david badill
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein
inaudible david nutt jimmy dore gad sad
blair white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford
to see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge metaphorically
speaking not just because they're
american our locals gives you access to
a great community of like-minded people
where you can share memes and make new
and problematic friends you also get
early access to live shows and we're
about to release details of our tour so
you'll want to know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below
or go to trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people today we are delighted to say
returning for the 73rd time it's our
brilliant friend andrew doyle who's of
course comedian satirist tv presenter
and the author of his latest book which
is called the new puritans how the
religion of social justice captured the
western world andrew welcome back thank
you for having me back it's great to
have you on how are you i'm all right i
have been on a lot you haven't haven't i
73rd is an exaggeration an exaggeration
it's actually 79. yeah because i was on
the second ever one you did you were and
you know what you confessed to us yes
that you were very skeptical about and
you nearly didn't come on the show in
fact you dedicated in this book you
talked about how that brief moment of
trust that you showed has resulted in
our friendship well exactly i've never
met either of you and i was very
paranoid that was my heist my paranoia
and i i almost didn't come because i
thought it was like a a setup i thought
you were going to do all these gotcha
questions and and try and make me look
like a fool i probably did look like a
fool but that wasn't because of your the
way you did it it was a great interview
was it all right yeah i hadn't watched
it back so i don't know it was great
but it got something like 13 000 views
or something like maybe given that we
had 13 subscribers at the time they each
watched it a thousand years yeah yeah it
was great and i will confess from our
end as well that we actually didn't know
that much about you no and
and we you we just knew that you were
writing for jonathan pie yes and we were
keen to speak to him
and to you because you're using me to
get to him exactly yeah
that's what we were doing but actually
it's funny how that's worked out because
he's obviously gone in his own direction
but i think you've contributed so much
to many of the conversations that we've
had and frankly to just the cultural
landscape in the uk you know and this is
one of the things that really
strikes me about you know the personal
stuff that you talk about in the book
because you open with a very old good
friend of yours a fellow colleague we
won't go into the details
um
you know going after you very hard yes
it was a weird one so i i mean this is
how i've opened the book because i think
so many people have lost friends through
this culture war
so many people i've spoken to sometimes
family members all over the slightest
point of political disagreement and um
this was an event that took place in a
bar in soho and i was out with this
married couple who i've known for many
years and we were having a great time
we're having drinks we were a bit tipsy
but about an hour in he started shouting
at me screaming at me calling me a nazi
and i thought it was a joke
and then i probed a bit and i realized
oh no it's not and he's been thinking
about this for a while and then i tried
to work out what it was and it turned
out it was because he didn't like that
i'd written for spiked magazine he he uh
i'd sat one of the jonathan pie videos
had satirized a point of view that he
held
and that was basically it and i couldn't
and i was like but that's not fascism
disagreeing with you slightly on
political issues is not the same as
calling for an ethnostate
you know it's just not the same so um it
was weird so really the book is about me
trying to make sense what kind of world
are we in now
where someone who knows me knows what i
believe knows that i'm a vocal opponent
of racism knows that i have no that
fascism is everything i stand against
knows that
nonetheless can convince himself and
this is an intelligent person that i'm
that i'm a nazi
what kind of world can we be in where
that can happen so my book's an attempt
to
explain
how we reach that point how do we reach
the point where
it's casually said in the mainstream
media that jk rowling is transphobic or
said transphobic things when she
actually has never said transphobic
things how are we in this position where
people are just buying into fantasies
even though the evidence is there should
you want to spend a minute to google it
what's going on uh so that's that's a
really good point andrew i've never i
think
those of us who've been sometimes on the
receiving end of some of the stuff we
haven't actually processed in some ways
what the significance of what you're
talking about like whether it's david
lammy going on on on the bbc and saying
that brexiteers the erg are worse than
nazis or your friend calling you that
like i don't think we've quite
understood like what what a deranging
world view it takes for someone to think
like that we've started to accept it
haven't we yeah i mean like even with gb
news if you think about when gb news was
announced four months before it was
aired you had thousands of activists and
mainstream commentators saying this is a
far right echo chain but no one has seen
it
no one knew what it would not even the
people who were in it knew what it was
at that point and then when it was on
the screens and it clearly wasn't that
and there were clearly a balance of left
and right wing views and people you know
gb news always makes an effort to bring
people in with different voices even
when it's clearly not what they said it
was they still say it is what the the
fantasy they decided on so so i think
all of this and there's so many examples
of this kind um you know
i'm sure you must have the same 99 of
the people who attack you online right
they will be people who've just decided
what you are and created this monster of
their imagination in order to attack um
i i rarely have uh an angry critic come
at me and faithfully replicate what i
think they'll say oh well you believe
this you believe this they often say i'm
a public
private privately educated
tory loving homophobe i get that a lot
it's like well i went to a comp i've
never voted tori and you know if i'm a
homophobe my boyfriend better be told
about that you know it's like it's it's
they're just so wrong
and even when you point out that they're
wrong and you say no this is what i
actually believe i mean look when i
announced this book the new puritans i
had loads of tweets saying we're going
to burn this book uh this is the sort of
book i would throw in the bin why are
you against social justice i'm like well
read the book
and you will understand that i'm not
against social justice i'm against
people co-opting the phrase but yeah but
it's become so
it is maddening that's the word that
you're right to use that word because
you know this is a movement
i think i think
everyone's baffled everyone's baffled
because you know most people are decent
people and they want everyone to have an
equal shot of things in life
and
this movement comes along that uses all
these really progressive sounding
phrases like social justice anti-racism
equity and so good people are like oh
okay well we should get on board with
that obviously
but they can sense and see that what the
movement's actually doing is against all
of those things it's creating more
racism it's dividing us
it's it's uh it's it's not advancing the
cause of social justice it's
legitimizing bullying it's uh it's a got
a vicious uh inhuman cruel quality about
it and we can see all of this stuff and
people can't say but they're confused
because it's sold to them in this
progressive language
so
one thing i really realized in in
writing the book is that this is a
battle the culture was a battle about
language and about who gets to define
words and so in order to ex
in the book i have to first explain what
the movement is
what it what its objectives are
what it achieves
and all of that is counter to how it
describes itself so it's really messy
and complicated that's why it needed a
full book because you can't just explain
that straight away you can't explain
you know if you take the phrase
anti-racism we're all against racism so
why would you object to the principle of
anti-racism until you read a book such
as how to be an anti-racist by abram x
kennedy and you realize that what he
means by anti-racism is not what we mean
by anti-racism what he means is being
proactive in the discovery of racism on
the assumption that all human
interaction is underpinned by racism and
that all white people are complicit in
white supremacy whether they want like
it or not that's the robin d'angelo take
on it that you know these are the the
and so therefore in fact alana lent he
put sorry ibrahim x kendi in his book
says that the dichotomy of not racist
and racist isn't real and that being not
racist is just another form of racism
similarly alana lenten who's another
critical race hustler said that um to be
not racist is a discursive form of
racist violence
so to be not racist is violent
so you've got these anti-racist
activists urging people to be racist in
order to not be racist it makes no sense
so you have to talk it through and
explain why if you're genuinely against
racism you have to be opposed to
anti-racism
so how do people make sense of that and
this is deliberate isn't it
if you redefine words and then deny that
you are redefining the words
you effectively end up gaslighting the
world and that word gaslight is their
word isn't it yeah i love it well it
comes from that 1940 film where you know
the husband is constantly lowering the
lights and the wife is saying why is it
getting dimmer in here and he's saying
no that's just your head it's all in
your mind and that's what they do to us
all the time so they'll say this is a
largely peaceful protest there's burning
buildings behind the guy but he'll just
say oh it's largely peaceful because
they think by describing something is
largely peaceful it becomes largely
peaceful everything's about the language
and they can deny the observable reality
in front of your eyes
and they'll do it and that will drive
you insane um and they'll blindside you
with jargon and they'll say you're too
stupid to understand critical race
theory even though the fundamental
precepts are not that difficult to grasp
and they'll throw jargon at you and
they'll put you off and um
actually
what i've what i've and what i've tried
to do in the book because i think
actually this stuff is understandable
and the only way we can defeat it is if
we get it if we have a secure grasp of
what it is they're doing and how to push
back against it so that's the point
sounds like the words of a nazi but
there we go
but the point you make about words is
very profound like when you were talking
about how they've changed the meaning of
words yeah and the most obvious
instance of this is the word woman
where suddenly we all knew what a woman
was
five six years ago but now the word
woman is up for grabs that's just insane
yeah and you can see when when a
politician is asked what is a woman you
have seen the they've started saying
that's like a gotcha question why are
you using these gotcha questions what is
a woman is not a gotcha question it's
actually a a means to test the honesty
of the ruling class
if if you can't sit there and tell me
what a woman is
then i don't trust you on anything else
because i know you know what a woman is
i mean this is the point you see the
fear in their eyes they're terrified
like they stammer they they they reach
they obfuscate they do anything but
answer the question
look i'm not
i don't think we can conduct this debate
with
you know
sorry
no no it's just
no no i just
and the reason they're so afraid is not
just because they're engaged in a lie
but because they know everyone knows
it's a lie you know this idea that none
of us know what the difference between
men and women we all know
the difference but we're expected to
proclaim that we don't that there is no
difference and that's that's why i think
that's a very good example of of
uh the the notion of a kind of it's not
just mass hysteria it's people going
along with the hysteria for the self
sake of self preservation
which is why in the book i've i've drawn
a lot of parallels with the salem witch
hunts because i think
there's a really good way to understand
what's going on at the moment if you
look back at that unique moment in
history which only lasted about a year
uh in the late 17th century in in salem
and you had a small community
by the way i mean the puritans of new
england were not witch hunters this is
not something they did in medieval
europe thousands of women were burnt as
witches this didn't happen the puritans
weren't like this this was a lapse it
was an aberration and what's so
interesting to me about that is you have
this community of decent
good people
who would suddenly believe there are
witches everywhere because this small
group of girls
claimed that they could see them
and so
uh and it only lasted that short period
of time
but what happened the key parallel here
is not just about the human
susceptibility for groupthink or the way
in which we go along with narratives if
we're told to it's not just that it's
it's that the elites were propagating it
so it would never have happened if when
these girls started screaming that there
are witches everywhere if the judges and
the magistrates and the ministers had
said no that's not true it would have
ended overnight but they didn't they
became complicit they said it is true
it's like our politicians they could all
say we all know what a woman is can we
stop this now
they don't they go along with it you
know and they say oh actually yeah there
is a so they go along with the activist
and they perpetuate the hysteria and
that's where i think the main
the main parallel between the two things
exists
um and the other thing about what i
found fascinating about the salem
instance is the more i read about it the
more i realized a lot of the elites
didn't believe it they just didn't
believe it there's a really interesting
moment where one girl
in court because you know they were
pointing the women on the stand saying
they were sending their shape out to
pinch them and torment them they would
say oh they've just their spirit has
just flown up to the beam i can see it
no one else could see it but it was the
girl's lived experience it was all the
all of the prosecutions were secured by
what they called spectral evidence we
call it lived experience what it means
is my truth i don't need evidence it's
just my truth i feel it therefore it's
true
so it's the same thing like just as
today the accusation of nazi fascist
racist homophobe is taken as proof
because that is the lived experience of
the accuser back in salem
this the spectral evidence was was taken
as proof
and they would say and as i was saying
though this one girl it's a really
interesting moment she pulls out a small
bit of knife uh something that's been
broken off a blade
and she's cut cut us down she says the
witch has just dug this into me and a
man at the court a local farmer said
that that's broke off my knife the other
day and you saw that happen and you
picked it up
and so
they knew she'd been lying but instead
of acknowledging this the magistrates
say oh well let's quickly move on to the
next thing there's loads if you read the
court records there's loads of examples
of you know they will accuse william
phipps the governor of the colony they
accused his wife
and the magistrates just said let's move
on
that's not real let's move on they
accused uh the acting president of
harvard college a guy called willow to
samuel willard uh they accused him and
the magistrate said you must be mistaken
you must be talking about constable
willard who's already in jail you've
already accused him you're getting
confused well does the devil get
confused or do the elites know actually
this isn't real but if we speak out
they'll accuse us
and that's where we're at today we all
know the difference between male and
female we all know that this anti-racist
movement is making society more racially
divided but if you say what everyone
knows you open yourself up to accusation
and you can be the next to be condemned
and it's a different form of
condemnation you know no one's going to
get hanged as the stakes were pretty
high in salem but we could you can have
your life destroyed your reputation
destroyed your career destroyed if you
if you say what we all know to be true
so there are
there are parallels and
and the other reason i wanted to talk
about that account is that it's a really
good way to get out of this there's a
lesson in salem of how to get out of
this
at firstly
it stopped because there was a tipping
point when too many people started
saying no the girls are lying there are
no witches
it just stopped that was one thing uh
the the second thing that happened is
that the
some of the i think it was the deputy
governor wrote to the leading clergymen
in the country and said can we use
spectral evidence can we prosecute on
the basis of spectral evidence and they
said no
that's not admissible
and so all of the things collapsed
overnight so i think it will just take
people to stand up and say no the
witches aren't real
we don't live in a country you know
which is full of fascists uh we we can
look at the evidence again and go by and
make our judgments based on evidence not
based on lived experience and feeling
and if everyone just did that if all the
people in power just did that this would
end and we'd be out of it but in the
play the arthur miller play it was john
proctor who had to sacrifice himself
in order that this could come to an end
well that was real i mean so when arthur
miller wrote the crucible yeah the the
figures in that who end up being hanged
rebecca nurse
john proctor etc they were real figures
who were hanged because they were so
devout they weren't prepared to say they
weren't prepared to lie to save their
necks
because they they believed in the the
everlasting perdition hellfire and
damnation they weren't going to damn
themselves by lying um but a lot of
people did a lot of people would just
say yeah i've i've met with the devil
because they were terrified of being
hanged and they said that they'd signed
his book and all the rest of it and of
course the puritans believed in mercy i
mean i call this book the new puritans
but they're nothing like the puritans of
old it's an analogy the puritans of old
really believed in mercy and they would
they had incredible leniency leniency
the courts would let you off if you
confessed to wishcraft um
but yeah you're right the john practice
of this world that also brought when
people like him when people like rebecca
nurse these local people who everyone
loved started being hanged
people got
concerned but
it needs people like that yeah and it
and what my worry is andrew is i see the
elites of people at the top
none of them have that level of
integrity no but like we do need people
like that and i think the way out of
this hysteria which is what i think it
is will come there will be people who
will be sacrificed along the way the
people who speak out earliest thanks for
looking at me
the people is people will be cancelled
they already have been yeah you know
people like jillian phillip rosie k you
people who've lost their jobs been
dragged through the courts all that sort
of stuff and it will continue to happen
but then it will reach a point where so
many people are getting cancelled
everyone will be like enough we're going
to speak out about it so i think yeah
you're right like some people will
you know it'll be horrible
but it makes it easier doesn't it for
the people to speak out later yeah it
does definitely
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrades your life
and well i was going to ask you
something else but before i do
where if we take the analogy that you've
given yeah of the witch trials in salem
and the process by which eventually
people come round to having a sensible
view of this yes
where are we on that journey with this
well i thought things were getting
better and then of course the the the
key events of the summer of 2020
where the culture were exploded into the
mainstream and all of the stuff that all
three of us have been talking about for
years remember how you people used to
dismiss us and say oh it's just a few
students you're you're whinging about a
few overzealous people on university
campuses no one says that anymore do
they because it's now in the mainstream
the evidence of what we've been talking
about is everywhere it's irrefutable
uh but it doesn't there doesn't seem to
be any sign of the momentum slowing does
that you don't think so
no not really there are let me put some
counter points to you which i've i've
been thinking about so as you know i've
said from day one that logically it
would be the trans thing that broke
intersectionality yes because the level
of suspension of disbelief
and the level of damage visible damage
that would be done in the name of trans
ideology yeah would would be difficult
even for people who are prepared to live
with a lot of cognitive dissonance i
agree to to to maintain that illusion
and we've seen the shutting down of
tavistock yes here in the uk we've seen
thousands of parents now suing tavistock
we see every day more and more
detransitioners i read this incredibly
powerful piece yesterday
by a parent who had transitioned i don't
know if you saw this it was it was
literally called i transitioned my child
i regret it or something like those
lines very very powerful you're starting
to hear these stories of people
who've gone along with this
and then either themselves suffered
through surgery and whatever or they've
they've hurt children yeah their own
children and those voices are more and
more
audible now to me
combined with you know changes in
reality in the clinic being shut down
the allison bailey case yeah the maya
four starter case you're starting to see
some shift on that issue are you not
you're not reassured that that is the
start of the momentum at least slowing
oh yeah i mean all of that stuff is
incredibly reassuring and i think that
those are signs that where
things might be healing but i think
because we obviously we talk to
like-minded people a lot we may be miss
how embedded this is you know i mean
closure of the tavistock is one thing
but look at the way that the trans
activists have tried to spin that as a
good news story and that actually just
means that they're going to be able to
open up gender clinics around the
country that are more localized of
course it's not good news for them
because it means that things will be
scrutinized more more closely but
absolutely i mean you're right that the
the extremity of what they are expecting
us to swallow uh will be its own undoing
right because look we all know that the
majority of gender non-conforming
children are gay or turn out to be gay
in later life so you are effectively
have a supposedly progressive movement
that is effectively medicalizing gay
kids and if you'd have said that to
anyone 10 years ago who would have
believed that that would be even
possible but do people fully understand
that gay and autistic okay and autistic
or people with other issues there will
be some children who have gender
dysphoria but they are the minority so
who would have believed that like 10
years back who would have thought that
was something that could potentially
happen and like salem it all burst out
very very quickly and ended very very
quickly this has all come about over the
past 10 years
and hopefully will burn out just as
quickly but it's going to take one major
tipping point i think i don't know
and i am reassured by by stuff like that
but look
do you remember there was someone put up
a composite image of all the labour mps
holding up a sign saying ban trans
conversion therapy right now of course
when you dig in that sounds great
because you conversion therapy you think
of like back in the day when they used
to put electrodes on gay men and try and
shock them out of their homosexuality
but of course it's not conversion
therapy when that what they call trans
conversion therapy is a specialist
a pediatric gender specialist talking to
a child to tease out what other possible
reasons there might be for this sense of
dysphoria be that homosexuality
internalized homophobia be that autism
all those kind of things that you
mention uh they say that's conversion
therapy
because they believe there's an innate
gendered soul and this person's just and
that it should be affirmed automatically
whenever anyone makes that claim so when
a labor politician holds up a sign
saying ban trans conversion therapy
they're effectively holding up a sign in
support of conversion therapy
because they are effectively putting gay
kids on a pathway to heterosexualize and
fix them
but do they understand that no if if
those politicians understood the
implications of what they were saying
they wouldn't hold up that sign
but we've reached the point where the
language has been redefined and shifted
so much that people don't understand
what it is they're supporting i'm
convinced that the majority of people if
they had a full grasp of what the social
justice movement is all about wouldn't
support it very very few would support
it even the 13 which is what the more in
common initiative uh found roughly 13
percent of the country would be
classified as woke would be classified
as supportive of these critical social
justice ideologies the various
interlapping strands of it um
even them if they understood what it was
they were supporting i think the
majority of them would back away in a
heartbeat you know the other good thing
by the way about that 13 figure is it
shows that these people because this is
of the culture was often
mischaracterized as the old failing to
keep up with the young failing to keep
up with changing trends but they are a
minority in every generation including
the young and that's bad news for the
activists yeah there's a higher
preponderance
of younger people but still the majority
of younger people are against it and if
those younger people understood that
they are actually supporting illiberal
dangerous divisive regressive ideas they
would back away too so it's all about
the way out i feel is all about
understanding is all about
exploding their myths you know they put
up this brick wall of language to deter
understanding and once you once people
understand what they're actually saying
uh then it won't be sustainable
and then just go go for it uh andrew i
was gonna
something i i hope you don't mind me
sharing with with our audience but when
we were in edinburgh we did a live show
together and before you know we spent a
bit of time together because with the
three of us we're always running around
we're super busy we actually even though
we're very good friends we don't
actually get to hang out that much no
but we did hang out a little bit and one
of the things i realized about your you
is that you were very very early to all
of this you were very early to all of
this so you the falling out with which
you begin the book
happened way before like francis and i
were doing trigonometry or any of that
you saw this
very very early yeah
first and really i want to ask you two
things about that first of all what was
that like for you
and secondly why do you think you saw it
that early
i think i think it's more i don't think
it's like i'm a nostradamus or anything
like that i think it's more that it's
not in my nature to
i can't just say something that i know
not to be true it's it's not something i
i can't do it so
for instance and because it all happened
so quickly like when the the brexit vote
happened in 2016. and because the left
and labor has always been anti-eu uh you
know
it was it was a sudden change it was a
sudden sea change overnight i mean like
even owen jones wrote an article saying
why we need to get out of the i think he
coined the phrase lexit why we need to
get out the eu this is a standard
left-wing position jeremy corbyn was
campaigning for 40 years to get out of
the eu you know um and all of a sudden
all my left-wing friends were saying
that oh yeah we're really pro-eu they
were really pro this trading block this
undemocratic bureaucratic trading block
that has capitalism in at the heart of
its constitution i'm like this isn't a
left-wing stance and um
so i uh when i did my show in edinburgh
the stand and 2016. so it was about a
month after the vote so it was around
the same time so i did a pro brexit set
effect i rewrote my show to talk about
that and that was that was a really fun
challenge because i had because i knew
all the audience would be remainers and
so i had to get them on side before i
dropped that into the show and that's
that was quite kind of fun um sometimes
it wouldn't go well
because it became hysterical
were running very hard yeah i mean i
realized this and i remember putting a
post on facebook just saying look can
everyone you know calm down a bit uh
we're not all evil
the thing got reduced
and it was the first time i've ever seen
this where a major political issue
in which everyone was engaged people
were more politically engaged than ever
people were having debates and
discussions in like pubs and you know
everywhere was it was really fascinating
um but it got reduced not just by
like people online but by mainstream
media as a debate between good and evil
a debate between racist and not racist
and i'm like this is not mapped onto the
reality and i started to notice this
vince cable stood up
at his spring conference and said that
the reason people voted to leave was
because they were nostalgic for the
empire which is just not a thing
there is no one who's nostalgic for
empire you might be able to find one or
two crackpots here and there there'll be
a colonel and there'll be someone yeah
right but none of us that's not a it's
just not a thing right so this complete
fantasy without any evidence he said
people were nostalgic for the time when
faces were white and passports were blue
and they the map the global map was
coloured pink who are you talking about
you've just decided this thing and
you've asserted it as though it's the
truth and it was the first time i was
really seeing stuff like that this
people who are mistaking their own
arguments for proof and it was happening
i know that's always happened to some
extent but this was happening across the
board and it was and the whole political
landscape was being dignified there were
villains and they were heroes and that
was it and i'm like this isn't real i
could tell none of this is real people
are getting upset painting their faces
with the eu flag they don't care about
the eu they didn't know what it was
three months ago right they they
certainly you know yeah i i was i talked
to people who were going to vote remain
and said well tell me about how the
commission works tell me about the
process they didn't know what it was
they didn't know what they were voting
for right they didn't they didn't even
bother to check so it was just about i'm
voting remain because i'm a good person
and because i'm
not racist
well you know the eu has some pretty
borderline racist policies it as it's
fortress europe immigration but it's
fine with freedom of movement within its
borders but when it comes to coming from
other continents it's pretty bad i mean
they're paying libyan warlords to keep
people in camps you know this so
it's incoherent to me to say that the
reason you vote to remain is because
you're pro-migration it doesn't make
sense but doesn't this
that point is very profound because this
is actually what all of this is about
which is people not analyzing what's
going on below the surface they just
take a very cursory glance at a very
complex issue like brexit or
issue like social justice
and they make up their own minds and
then they go with it because because
they are told that these people are on
the side of the angels and and you know
if the girls are pointing and crying
which so we'll go along with the girls
because they're they're they're doing
god's work
and also if i don't they'll point at me
and cry witch so it's the same thing
with brexit and then it was the same
thing with trump and everything got
reduced to
you know good and evil and it's like
nothing is ever about good and evil
there are no good and evil people it's
like solzhenitsyn says you know were it
possible to just separate humanity into
good and evil and put all the evil
people on an island somewhere that would
be great but as he says the the line
between good and evil cuts through the
heart of every human being and you're
not going to cut out a piece of your own
heart what about australia though yeah
yeah okay
so they're all evil yeah um but
yeah no but this is this is the thing
we're going to get
we're going to get so many emails now
but just just for a cheap joke andrew i
didn't mean to cheap on the point and i
agree with you i i i i realize i've gone
off to tanja but you haven't it relates
to what you were saying about
why in in the comedy industry when i did
that show in 2016 and i was just saying
what i knew to be true and
i made it funny obviously i hope um
but i realized then something was going
on because
i think
comedians start i remember one comic who
i'd known for a while saying to me i
hear you're supporting
uh brexit i thought you were intelligent
and then people were blocking me that
i'd known for years on social media
comics comedians
uh and then some of them were nervous
about some of the jonathan pie videos
i'd written which was satirizing stuff
that they didn't and i started noticing
oh because it used to be i used to just
assume well we can disagree right and we
can i used to disagree with friends all
the time it was fun yeah and we'd have
debates and stuff and then suddenly the
climate shifted and to disagree meant
you were the you were the heretic you
were evil
and so i don't think it was me noticing
stuff earlier i think it was just me
i wasn't prepared
to just lie i you know i mean brexit
you the number of comics who were openly
pro-brexit you could count on one of abu
hamsa's hands right
none that was that [ __ ] hit by four
of us yeah
and it be and you became like a pariah
and
andrew but
you you're someone who's got an
incredible amount of fortitude but that
must have been difficult to see that
happen i was just surprised uh that
well i mean the the account i give in
the book of that there's things like
that the extreme things where people
scream you're a nazi uh there's no but
even the fact that you were worried
about coming to talk to us because you
were so concerned about you know being
misrepresented being attacked you know
well at that time especially though i
didn't understand it i i saw these
things online people kept saying to me
online things that i didn't believe as
though i believed them you know we know
that you believe this we know that you
support free speech because you support
racists and you want racist to be able
to say what they want
and i'm like i don't support race where
have i ever said i support race you're
just making something up and describing
it to me and at that point now i sort of
understand why it happens more and more
because it's easier to fight with a
figment of your imagination and actually
engage with what people say but
back then i didn't get it i didn't
understand it and i was very mistrustful
of people asking for interviews yeah um
because i thought it was always going to
be a hit job yeah you know so that's and
i'd never heard of youtube no offense
like we hadn't gigged together yeah yeah
like so i i was like i'm unbelievable
you come in here you're insulted faces
i've never heard you but you didn't know
who i was either you know so it's like
but i i it's not i'm not trying to dig
up that incident i guess what i'm
getting at is you it's not been easy
like i i'm not you're not someone who
complains about it it's just occurred to
me that
being first through the breach you
always take most of the arrows you know
what i mean well i i still to this day
don't quite understand when i s when i
catch a you know because so many
comedians don't talk to me they've
unfriended me and all the rest of it but
when i catch a glimpse of something they
say online uh
you know
i i'm like i don't recognize myself
there like uh
like just casually referring to me as
evil or
or like like a far right
person and it's like but i'm
clearly not yeah but but if you've just
decided that i am i mean some someone
comedian wrote a blog about the comedy
unleash night recently which is the
night i run and they start to talk about
how
the acts at comedy elise just go on
stage to spout racism and attack
minorities which has literally never
happened at comedy unleashed and i
wouldn't book that person because that
person isn't going to be very funny
that's just not a thing again it's like
so i don't know even how to
i'm continually surprised by it because
i'm like why would you be happy to just
live in a fantasy world why would that
make you why not why is there not the
slightest point of curiosity if i
thought there was a far right comedy
night going on i might want to see what
they're actually saying there and the
thing is a great thing you can because
so many of the videos are online and
when you watch them you realize it's
just it's comedy unleashed is just
another comedy night where you know
where the often people come and do the
same sets they do elsewhere it's just
that every now and then we cultivate an
audience that isn't going to complain
about being offended we cultivate an
audience that is comedy literate and
understands uh that you know the
comedian on stage is not literally
expressing their opinions yeah that
they're expressing jokes um and every
now and then a comedian will fire me up
and say can you can i do this night
because i don't feel i can try this new
material anywhere else right and that's
a perception in the industry whether
people deny it but it is a perception um
it's not that we've set up a night to
platform far-right people because we
hate minorities or that we think that
other that comedians can't say what they
want on other platforms or on other
stages that isn't what we're doing at
all it's but it's a weird i mean look
when we announce the comedy unleash tour
recently the hysteria from comedians was
hilarious one guy started saying if you
do this tour you're a [ __ ] scab
i'm an anarchist and this is a guy's got
a radio 4 show so he's not that much of
an anarchist
you know it's like it's weird and then
the blog and all these people going up
on about attacking the comics on the
bill
you know and and the the comics we have
are from a broad spectrum of political
views uh they're mostly left-wing
because there's more left than
right-wing comics but there are some
right-wing comics there as well there
are different comedic styles the key
things they're just all really funny and
interesting and
you know that are prepared to sometimes
put some of them push the boundaries not
all of them even that's not even a
criteria um but it was just it's like so
there's a tour going around the country
which just has a variety of different
acts and people come along and laugh and
people are reacting as though it's like
a far-right rally or something it's
weird to me i don't
you know i'm i'm perpetually baffled by
it but
the whole thing is weird let's just be
honest this what you've written about is
[ __ ] weird
it is
you see them talk to one another and
like some of them are considered my
friends at one point i mean they
probably don't consider me a friend
anymore but they just gotta hate you
know yeah they do they do they'll just
say things like in casual conversation
like i'm a cis man
what the hell is going on yeah you know
i'm a cis white man it's just
it's infected language and it's effect
infected their world view but it's
utterly normalized around these people
it's weird isn't it it's it's when um
the
the left took a turn from class
to group identity uh that's
you know that's what what happened here
and like i try and explain this thing in
the book and i see it as like a kind of
hydra with many heads you know because
you've got you've got a a strand about
race gender and all these things are
different like critical race theory is
very different from queer theory say but
they all come from the same wealth
spring they all come from the same
fundamental post-modern assumptions that
for instance uh our understanding of
reality is constructed through the
language that we use that's why they're
all obsessed with language and
manipulate the manipulation of language
so they all have a shared body just many
different strands and and therefore it's
really hard to describe them because
what do you call them because they they
wage the war through language you know
well for a start they called themselves
woke in 2015 they were all calling
themselves woke and jack dorsey went on
stage with a stay woke t-shirt nika
burns launched the edinburgh festival by
saying the next generation of comics are
going to be woke and we look forward to
comedy's new woke world no one said oy
why are you using a right-wing slur
no one said that's a snarl word but then
because people like us started using the
word to describe them because that was
the word they were using themselves that
was a courtesy i was just using their
word right and then they say no it's
just a right-wing snarl word to attack
us to denigrate us anyone who uses the
word and so but i'm like but i can
google that and like 10 minutes ago you
were calling yourself woke we can check
that but they don't care about that
because they just deny reality um so
in other way if you can't name an enemy
you can't defeat that enemy in the
marketplace of ideas so that any term
that we come up with to describe them
they will problematize
so i call it the critical social justice
movement but that's kind of difficult to
explain you have to sort of explain it
first
you could call them leftist
identitarians but they're not meaningful
extreme progressivists but that's
misleading as well because they're not
progressive they're regressive i agree
so so whatever we come up with
there isn't a way to sort of pin them
down
and that's and that's another reason i
wrote the book because i want to try and
pin them down and i call them the new
puritans because the the analogy of
puritanism as being you know it's been a
colloquial
term for many years which we all
understand as meaning someone with a
precisionist and prohibited
prohibitionist tendency priggish if you
like uh
intolerant sensorial i'm not making i've
had lots of christians get onto me
they're very angry i'm not they usually
are yeah but i'm not attacking the
puritans of old i'm very clear that
there's a distinction whereas the
puritans of old believed in their they
had a constant awareness of their
fallibility they were constantly
doubting themselves they didn't know if
they were part of the elect or the
damned they they they knew that they
were unworthy before god the new
puritans don't they have extreme
certainty you hear the way they talk
never never crosses their mind they
could be wrong you know so i'm not
saying they're the same i'm using
a shorthand so that we can understand
who they are and where they're coming
for that's the attempt anyway whether it
works or not
hey francis do you believe in diversity
and inclusion of course i do my dating
history is filled with diversity and
inclusion i am nothing if not an equal
opportunities employer all your previous
partners do seem to be of the same sex
i'm not that inclusive but if you are
worried about the polarizing effect of
diversity and inclusion in workplaces
then you have to attend the
counterweight conference on liberal
approaches to diversity and inclusion
we've had people from counterweight on
this very show to talk about how this
can be achieved they're great people who
want to improve society counterweight
believe that there is a need for
diversity and inclusion that aims to
eliminate workplace racism and
discrimination through a liberal and
unifying lens the current way isn't
working and we need a less divisive
approach the speakers are also former
guests of ours including eric kaufman
they're also giving free access for a
very limited time to a huge variety of
resources showing how diversely and
inclusion can be done properly without
the all the reactory nonsense peddled by
those who shall not be named so if
you're interested in making your
workplace better for everyone then you
have to check out the counterweight
conference on liberal approaches to
diversity and inclusion we promise there
won't be any lectures with titles like
why painting your bathroom why is a
microaggression it's an online
conference on the 22nd to the 25th of
september go to cw dot h e y s u m m i t
dot com and use our code trigger pod 20
at checkout for 20 off an all-access
pass go to
cw.heysummit.com and use our code
triggerpod20 at checkout for 20 off and
all access pass
just like stalin
we'll probably won't include that no no
no i don't think we will
but you said that they're not
progressive they're aggressive i would
push back on that because they wouldn't
identify as being regressive they're
utopians
they want to get to this magical utopia
yeah and they think that if they keep
doing what they're doing and you know
they force out all the bigots or racists
of transpose all of this they stamp it
out they destroy it we're going to get
to this beautiful utopia where we're all
equal well right
and it's not true because humankind is
messy yeah and the great thing about the
liberal project i mean they they reject
liberalism quite explicitly so if you
read the foundational text of critical
race theory they describe it as being an
anti-liberal movement they don't believe
in liberalism and they say
we live in a society where racism still
exists therefore the liberal project has
failed social liberalism has failed but
of course social liberalism never makes
any claims that it can make humankind
perfect it's an ongoing project and
whereas what we do as liberals is
address
racism and injustice as and when it
happens what they do is they try and
seek it out in the shadows and identify
where it may not exist and often doesn't
exist so they will call an institution
they will say it's institutionally
racist they'll say oxford university is
institutionally racist and then someone
else might say but the data shows that
incidents of racism at oxford are really
rare they barely happen at all it
doesn't matter because we have some
lived experience of someone who's you
know so therefore you know it must be so
that's the way they operate um and
i don't think they are progressive and i
think we do need to push back in the way
that you're describing but
but okay i think why it's become so
difficult is whereas before
this was being peddled by activists
online with anime avatars or like the
people you can safely ignore the
screamers you know um the the insane
ones
but now it's it's
it's from the elites and it's from the
people in power
uh you know the the the these ideologues
dominate the civil service they dominate
the nhs the army the police the
government by the way the tory
government has presided over most of
this over the past 12 years yep right
they have just instituted the online
harms bill online safety bill used to be
the harms bill which talks about legal
but harmful speech harmful speech so
they're using the lexicon of critical
social justice they're part of the
problem when you try and describe the
culture as a left versus right issue you
completely misapprehend what's going on
yeah there's a problem in all political
parties we can't vote these people out
you can vote in a labor government or
tory government you're still going to
get the woke because if the civil
servants it's service if the machinery
of government is grinding in that
direction there is nothing you can do
and that's why this is a problem because
it is everywhere it's in all major
institutions and look at what's happened
with the leadership election where the
one candidate who actually was talking
quite a bit of sense on these issues
yeah was quite purposely excluded quite
from the vote by members who would have
overwhelmingly have voted for kim
obedient and this is why i think when
you say that you're more positive about
the movement
because it hasn't been rooted out among
the echelons of power that's where i get
nervous and it's so easy to dismiss and
mischaracterize what's going on here you
know we get these stories every now and
then of like uh someone puts a trigger
warning on hemingway's the old man and
the sea and this did happen at
university and they put a trigger
warning saying it contains scenes of
graphic fishing
and uh what graphic fishing yeah that
was the trigger warning the animal
cruelty i guess graphic fishing yeah
yeah it's pretty graphic because he
hangs the fish on the side of his boat
and the sharks eat them bit by bit so
yeah it's quite graphic um but it's
still fishing and they they they put a
trigger warning on robert louis
stevenson's kidnapped saying it contains
themes of kidnapping which is implied in
the title similarly julius caesar
apparently it's got a plot that is it
does someone gets stabbed someone gets
stabbed
don't read the book you'll be very upset
about it yeah it's absolutely graphic um
so all of this stuff is funny right and
we can laugh at this
but then take a step and think is it
that funny because this isn't some
activist online saying this these are i
never found this funny andrew i never
found this funny because like you i can
play the movie forward yeah and if you
play the movie forward you can see where
this goes there's no there's no question
about it that if this movement was
allowed to carry on down that path
the damage that would be done and this
is as you know the point i make in my
book uh which is if the west continues
to engage in this it opens up the door
for other hostile actors to come in and
take advantage of our division and
weakness can we talk about the nonces
the what the nonsense the nonsense yeah
you've got a whole chapter on the
non-philosophers okay
i've got a chapter on the origins of
this yeah um of this thing um
and yes it does a lot of it does come
from the post-modernist of the 1960s the
french post-modernist jean-francois
leather jacques derrida uh michelle
foucault being the most obvious ones um
there's an element to of uh
uh themes and ideas from the frankfurt
school most notably the you know people
like adorno and max horkheimer people
like that the the the mistrust of the
masses that very much is something that
comes from the you know they think that
you know how like
uh social justice activists they they
they want to take scenes out of comedies
that they seem problematic which is
streaming services are now doing of
course or they want to ban films or
various books you know whatever uh that
comes from this idea that if the masses
are
exposed to popular entertainment they
can be corrupted and that's that's
something that has echoes of what they
believed in the frankfurt school um you
know the cancellation of jerry
sadowitz's show you know that's an adult
show that is advertised at adults with
so many warnings saying what it is but
the pleasants have said we need to
decide on your behalf whether you can
buy tickets for that it's not safe for
you to buy tickets for that and they
actually said you know it's harmful they
described it as harmful um but that
means that they believe in this idea
that popular entertainment can corrupt
the masses which was the identical
perspective that mary white has had well
it's a very socially conservative point
of view if you think about it which is
like you know the the the the low leap
whatever yeah masses must be beings the
plebeians must be protected from the
corrupting influence of
you know
degrading art and culture and whatever
exactly and to go back to your question
for co
uh and it's principally for code that
they cite they don't cite marcusa of the
frankfurt school even though he wrote an
essay on repressive tolerance where he
was very explicit about the need to
effectively not allow conservatives to
speak
not a lot of right-wingers to speak so
it's interesting that they don't cite
that more yeah but they do cite foucault
and they won't have read him and what's
interesting about like like all
religions a lot of the faithful don't
read the holy text yeah you know and i
had to read a lot for her because i was
teaching him and i was i know and he
formed a major aspect of my doctoral
thesis so you know i was already steeped
in this kind of stuff but in short the
most important thing is is for belief in
this nexus of power and language yes
that he sees power as not being this top
down phenomenon but it runs through all
strata of society like a grid that runs
through and that's why they always bang
on about power structures and the way in
which language or jokes normalize hate
or legitimize violence that's how they
see it
they see this as a fundamentally
linguistic discourse that's how they
comprehend reality so you do need to
understand where it's come from i think
and that's why i don't want to alienate
people who go into it too much it's just
one chapter i just talk about those
origins in a hopefully accessible way
but the reason i brought up the the
nonsense as a sort of jokey point is
that i mean we know that foucault
was a bit partial to that sort of thing
he slept with underage boys yes
and
some people i i see this online i don't
know what it you know how much basis
there is to but i'm increasingly
concerned that this
process of never-ending deconstruction
yeah is aimed at deconstructing all
sorts of social norms and one of them
you know once you get past
deconstructing the idea of sex and
gender
then the next thing is to start calling
pedophiles minor attracted people and on
and on it goes
what do you make of all of that
uh i think i'm concerned when i see
activists and academics which are
basically the same thing now
um
basically talk about um
uh minor attractive persons and how
maybe we should bring them into the
lgbtqia umbrella and all of that and the
thing is it is very few people are
saying that and we do have to be clear
about it i don't think this is a common
thing at all and i think it's a bit
conspiractorial to say yes because
foucault had these tendencies therefore
he's developed these theories that now
other you know secret nonsense you do
think that's conspiratorial that his
theories were partly produced by
you know i don't know why he yeah
yeah you're not a reminder why he
created the theories he created but i
think but the person who sort of you
know was at the the foundation of
transgenderism also yes had john money
yeah yeah so you're like to me that is
not insignificant it's not insignificant
um because it's morally reprehensible
behavior um but it's like why would we
why would we design society around the
ideas of two pedophiles is i guess
that's not why those ideas took hold
though yeah people were in within
academia people weren't elevating
foucault i mean people really did
there's even a guy called david halperin
who wrote a book called saint phuket
towards a gay hagiography he literally
deifies i mean when i was a at
university foucault was like a god and
people would invoke him
and that was the sort of an end of
discussion and i was very skeptical
about foucault and you know i didn't
think he was a good historian and and i
i wanted to talk about this stuff and um
i remember being at a conference and
this academic talked about how
foucault for comb mentioned that uh this
particular sexual activity wasn't or
didn't happen in the ancient world and i
asked the question i said how did he
know
and they didn't know why he knew and he
used to do he just assert this stuff
it's shoddy stuff really but but
theoretically
those ideas caught on
almost by accident it wasn't because of
what he thought about it's i kind of
feel sometimes this stuff just happens
accidentally a little bit you know these
ideas become fashionable fashion
explains an awful lot yes and then all
of a sudden people are like and also
deconstructing the text is fun right if
you take that approach when i was
studying an undergrad at the english
literature we weren't really reading a
poem for its
its artistry for its numinous quality
for its for for the poetry of the thing
we were trying to work out which bits
are sexist which bits are homophobic
which bits are racist and then write up
that up in an sn you get first
it was moral detective work
right it's it's you know you you it's
really boring actually teasing out the
contradictions in the text trying to
work out problematizing the text look i
used to do it myself you know i used to
do it about about shakespeare and and
and
and
i find that sort of stuff embarrassing
now but
um that and it's easier it's it's an
easier approach and it's also you know
my supervisor robin robbins who i've
dedicated the book to i um he said to me
once that
all of this sort of um
uh post-modernist uh fashion within
english literature those books get
published because the publishers don't
understand the jargon so you have people
like judith butler dressing
what is a relatively simple idea up in
20 different clauses
over overloading a really turgid prose
that is just jargon-laden and unpleasant
to read and lacking in clarity but these
are ideas that can be expressed with
elegance should you wish to do so
there's smart ideas and i do understand
that difficult ideas sometimes take
difficult terms to explain them but not
those ideas and and so he was saying
that's why these things get published
also these theorists were constantly
quoting each other creating this
illusion that they'd generated this body
of knowledge that they were important
but they're just quoting each other and
they're flimsy ideas i mean that and
that's how i think it took on i don't
think it was
queer theorists trying to normalize
pedophilia i don't think that's what was
happening there interesting andrew do
you think part of it as well is
it just makes you feel good oh yeah like
there's nothing more fun than sort of
judging someone else and saying i'm more
morally superior than you oh brilliant
isn't it just going look how great i am
the pharisees had a great time didn't
they yeah you know of course and and
yeah there's partly that there's an
excuse you know look the inquisitors who
were strapping women to the rack back
and they were they thought they were
good people
and and it's great because you can
behave cruelly and you can bully people
but you can still call yourself a saint
i mean what what's not to like right you
know and and so many of these people do
this um but also in addition to that and
again i think that's sort of veering
into trying to work out motives and i
don't think we necessarily can uh do
that
um
i think the other possibilities people
do they genuinely have
bought into it they genuinely believe it
how could it be otherwise you know when
you get like
it was in ontario wasn't it last year
where a school board
not just a school board a body of 30
schools the board that controls 30
schools removed 5 000 books from the
library shelves because they had
outdated depictions of race and they
burnt a number of them
and they called this a flame
purification ceremony
and then they used the ashes of the
burnt books to fertilize a new tree
isn't that beautiful and and
they obviously think this is this is
fahrenheit 451 but they think this is
yeah but
to do something that's
self-satisfied not just activists that's
a school board that controls 30 schools
right it's a major body that's why it
matters right if it's just activists
burning books they do that all the time
with jk rowling's books and stuff
they've threatened to burn my book right
um i don't care about that they can burn
as many books as you want something you
buy it first right do that but when a
school board a county school board not
only removes the books from the shelves
but burns them
and calls it a flame purification
ceremony
and they can't see what the implications
of that are i don't believe they could
have done that if they could see with
any sense i think they must have bought
into this they must think that those
books are dangerous historical books
that represent people in a way the
reason why dr seuss the estate of dr
seuss is no longer publishing six of his
books because of outdated racial
stereotypes enid blyton they'll talk
about her outdated racial stereotypes
they republish mark twain's huckleberry
finn without the racial epithets doesn't
make sense because it's an anti-racist
book it's a book that satirizes these
these sort of priggish
self-righteous good christian people who
nonetheless enslaved their fellow human
being and it takes a boy to see through
that right that's an anti-racist book
and once you take those racial epithets
out it doesn't work the satire loses its
teeth
so to kill a mockingbird you know again
they can only see the language they only
see the racial epithet and to kill a
mockingbird and they ignore the message
of the book it's kind of like people who
don't understand comedy particularly
satire satirical comedy they just they
can't understand that somebody could be
in a character on stage
saying something that they don't believe
that they're it's incredible how
humorless these people are
and uh i i do find that very strange but
andrew um the the new puritans i i
really recommend people get this book uh
and have a have a good read of it and um
we're gonna ask you some questions for
our locals but i will finish oh just one
question that i want to ask and the one
thing i want to push back you say you
can't
look into other people's uh you know
minds and blah blah blah blah blah blah
i i know you can yeah of course i can
but look that we all know some very very
dodgy people in our industry yeah and
they're always the most work yeah
yeah sure
there is that coincidence isn't there
but um why do you think that might be
because i think they use it as a tool to
shield and protect themselves and also
attack other people who they perceive to
be their enemies and i also think that
is very likely what i won't say is that
i definitively know i don't know why
maybe they have bought into it but it's
look
i mean i say in the book you know some
people don these sacred robes
out of a sense of duty and some people
don them as a disguise and we'll never
know which is which what we all we can
do is really push back against the
argument and push back against the ideas
you know if
you know if you're propagating these
terrible ideas that are making society
more racially divided uh that are
attacking gay kids all of that sort of
stuff and you're doing it for nefarious
reasons
uh or you're doing it because you
sincerely believe it actually doesn't
matter either way
we still need to treat take the argument
at face value push back at it an
argument stanza falls on its own merits
not whether the person sincerely holds
the belief so it's just it's just more
sensible i i argue to to assume good
faith
and destroy the argument anyway and
that's the best way because also the
other thing is if you don't do that
you're doing what they do
you're you're on their level there you
know because when i present arguments in
defense of free speech
they make these claims that i'm you know
as i said earlier that i'm support
trying to support fascism
and you know that's not an argument is
it so
i mean that's that would be my advice or
you know even if you know they're lying
or you're pretty sure just
these arguments fall apart really easily
it doesn't depend on their sincerity
right
andrew thank you so much for coming back
uh the new puritans make sure to go out
and grab that uh and andrew we're gonna
ask you a couple of questions that our
local supporters have already submitted
okay i'm nervous but before we do before
we do uh we as always have the final
question which is what is the one thing
we're still not talking about as a
society that you think we should be
okay and i knew you were going to ask
this and every time you ask me this i i
i i forget that i was freeze i was meant
in the headlights
isn't that funny is the only thing that
i struggle to answer
is that what do i think we're talking
about that we
i don't think we don't sorry what do i
think we're not talking about that we
should be talking about um
what is an issue that you don't think
gets enough attention that actually
really matters
well to be honest it's the issues that i
wrote in the book which i know we talk
about them a lot but i don't think the
mainstream art particularly you know i
cover a lot of these issues on my show
on gb news
um and other news channels just don't
touch them and so i think we often fall
into the trap of assuming that because
we talk about them everyone's talking
about them actually most people aren't
and most people don't understand it i
mean you mentioned earlier people
describe themselves as cis i would
suggest that most people still don't
know what cis means
and and they certainly don't understand
that you know if you don't believe you
have a gender identity if you don't
subscribe to that ideology describing
yourself as cis is incoherent like
describing anyone as cis is incoherent
because the word means someone whose
body biological sex aligns with the
their gender identity but you can't call
someone that if they don't believe in
gender identity it doesn't make any
sense so
so i would say
yeah the issues that we've we are
talking about now are the things that
most people aren't talking about now
that might be a bit of a cop-out
no but no that makes sense to me that
makes sense okay great cop out andrew
there we go andrew doyle thank you so
much for coming back and thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out at 7 pm uk time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys we'll see on
locals
[Music]
does titania ever have sex to tonya
mcgraw
[Music]
you